[Musique]
aux portes du quartier la petite
bourgogne à montréal une cantine nouveau
genre a élu domicile en pleine pandémie
c'est mon rêve moi j'ai rêvé ça et j'ai
décidé de prendre mon courage à deux
mains ed réaliser c'est le rêve de
jackson joseph était d'offrir ici une
cantine haïtienne aux saveurs créoles
mois cantine pour moi ça fait quelque
chose de plus accessible et plus
abordable de plus convivial de propre et
en sueur
c'est fait pour les gens par les gens
[Musique]
ici le service est rapide mais on est
loin de la frite et du hot-dog selon
jackson l'offre alimentaire des comptes
il est en voie de se transformer le fast
food a fait son temps et puis je pense
qu'on est présents malades gisent sur le
feu le soul food doit prendre le dessus
parce qu'ici nouvelles ce qui est
réconfortant au moins c'est nourrir
l'âme sessegnon glam c'est quelque chose
qui est le confort enquête chaleureux et
puis qui quittent fait du bien mais qui
tient aussi aux à
nourrir l'âme avec de la nourriture
maison authentique de quoi rappeler la
cuisine de rue en haïti mais là bas il
faut se déplacer de kiosque en kiosque
pour composer son menu mais souvent il
ya des plats comme ça qu'on trouve que
c'est vraiment le yoyo avec tous
meilleurs pas le oui tout ça lui il
s'appuie comme une plus grosse
installation
à la cantine burns le menu typiquement
haïti- et réunis sous le même toit clan
des récollets condiments pic lise
pimentée et le fameux griots de la chef
maria un logo c'est du port il y faut
vraiment aller c'est bien cuire beaucoup
de temps au moins de trois heures le
temps ses cuisses sûr que la viande va
être déjà cuit à moins de trois heures
de temps mais ça va pas et tendres
tendres à l'intérieur croustillantes à
l'extérieur la finition se fait à la
friteuse souvent je vais prendre soin de
griots ou bien le boeuf cette fois ci
c'était avec buvait des planteurs
lericolais et le plantain ses
incontournables de la cuisine créole
font aussi le bonheur des habitués du
quartier c'est vraiment délicieux les
plantains sont vraiment bien fait
les plates et ça comme c'est la cerise
sur le gâteau c'est comme un dj quelque
chose qu'on met pour gâteries
[Musique]
ce fidèle de la cantine bugs vient très
souvent peut-être une fois par semaine
au moins régulièrement oui ça fait
vraiment partie des réseaux préférés ils
raffolent lui aussi du riz coller aux
fèves rouges c'est vraiment très
étonnant parce que justement c'est un
avis qui est légèrement free et qui va
chercher beaucoup beaucoup de saveurs
avec des pois l'intérieur c'est des
choses changent vraiment de ce que j'ai
a justement j'ai pas d'ombré kinase été
indien magida lericolais vous savoir
comment faire confiance et a ajouté löw
met relevé quels sont les ingrédients
qui composent ans mais je
vis comme aimait beaucoup de temps et
beaucoup d'amour maria veut pas révéler
tous ses secrets non pas du tout
[Rires]
la cantine est aussi un lieu pour
célébrer l'héritage du quartier et sa
riche communauté noire est ce que je
vais faire ici dans la trentaine quand
j'ai le temps je change avec les gens
sur l'histoire mon partage que ce qu'on
sait de l'histoire ont fait que pour moi
sympa
quartier saint roch à québec dans un
recoin de la rue saint-joseph une autre
cantine nouveau genre une petite
terrasse abrite des listes l'asie du
sud-est de mon jean que les restaurants
asiatiques à québec ce à quoi nous
apporter d'autres sont couverts step à
orléans beaucoup aussi la cantine bâti
c'est le rêve de sao couronne également
propriétaire du restaurant juste à côté
fermé pendant la pandémie son but faire
découvrir la cuisine de rue cambodgienne
bonne partie des roms accessible pour
partie parce que je voyais dans l'avenir
d'art une demande pour cela résultat un
succès monstre avec plus de 2000
commandes par semaine la pandémie savent
juste explosé quand j'ai une
augmentation de 80 personnes c'est ce
que j'avais à par la police
au bout de la petite terrasse une porte
de garage où les clients et les livreurs
se croisent sans cesse l'expérience
rappelle celle du cambodge pratiquement
les maisons commerces ont le portail rh
n'ont cessé ce niveau on doit user
extérieure et ses amis présents à
maxime exposantes savoir sa vie avec ses
et sucrés allègrement
saveurs qui par phénicie le poulet et le
tofu khmer à la citronnelle ou encore le
plat de boeuf chorale trois magnifiques
l'ingrédient secret de la cantine bâti
la collaboration de toute la famille
couronne qui travaille en restauration
depuis des décennies à québec
pour mon sens une source de complexité
générée
[Musique]
par
les grillades sont à l'honneur et sont
préparés devant les clients en terrasse
sur un yakitori un green très utilisé en
asie
à la maison sans carbone est un poisson
comme j'ai dit ça marche pas les clients
viennent aussi pour cette entrée
végétarienne déboulé de maïs préparé
avec soin par kim samedi la nièce de ça
où
on mélange
les quelques pas de tango
ti
grand objectif a montré que cela
vaudrait confortons cambodgien as tu es
maintenant les gens aiment ce commet
tous cambodgienne il pense à 26 je pense
que j'ai réussi ce mois sao et jackson
ont réussi en osant changer le paysage
des cantines au québec il nous donne
accès aux saveurs d'ailleurs tout près
de chez nous je commençais à l'étude je
pense que j'ai gagné
[Musique]